in addition to being a Harvard Lutheran
chaplain I'm also the senior pastor of
University of Lutheran Church which is
right next to Pinocchio's and we host
the Harvard Square homeless shelter as
you probably know the Harvard Square
homeless shelter is completely operated
by Harvard undergrads with lots of
support from the community and it is
through being in that space and being
hospitable that I have a lot of
opportunity to interact and meet
students from all different faiths all
walks of life people of all walks of
life and what I am always hoping for is
that there in our congregation space in
our ministry space that it's a
comfortable safe peaceful environment
where people know they can be themselves
take risks and conversations ask
questions and just be really curious
about the bigger issues of life and the
meaning of things I'm a native of
Chicago and being here in Cambridge I
find really hospitable I'm an urban
spirit I especially love the red line
you can feel it
on the Harvard campus it's rumbling
underneath you and it's how I get to get
to work in the mornings and the red line
is very special because compared to some
of the other lines on the MBTA we sit
across from one another and over the
course of three or four stops there is
the whole breadth of humanity all ages
people from all around the world people
who don't share a common language but
are somehow on a common journey for
three or four or five stops and the kind
of glimpses of how humanity's better
side better
angels can come out to be supportive as
you sit across from one another I just
really loved that when I was an
undergraduate going to church seeking
out a minister or priest wasn't on my
radar but it was there two things that
happened actually one was it was a time
of social ferment there were moments of
great upheaval the Vietnam War
corresponding to today we've had we've
had the Marathon bombing to respond to
as a community there are these times I
think in every decade and probably more
often than we would hope for where
there's a challenge to make sense out of
things when they're really coming apart
quite surprisingly to me when I was a
student it was it was a priest Father
James Carroll who is today a very
well-known novelist and essayist and an
author but he was a voice within the
church who was open to holding many
things in tension not saying here's the
right answer here's the wrong answer but
these things are complicated and as a
community we can do deep listening
together we can share what we're enraged
about we can share what we're feeling
isolated about and as a community we can
approach maybe just a little more solid
footing not any big answers but a way
through and so it's been a very long
journey since then but I
always go back to that kind of
hospitality that was supplied to me at a
time of great questioning and hope that
I with my community can be that space of
trust and listening for for others